hello everyone and welcome to the most
awaited game of the round it is the
local Hero anishigiri vs world champion
Magnus Carlsen and they both had a a set
of very good three rounds uh Anisha uh
defeated Lucas in that very nice game
that we've covered the beautiful
sacrifice of the Knight on G5 and Magnus
won that very nice positional
Masterpiece against Vincent kaimer uh
but both of them with two two additional
draws uh now they face each other let's
check it out it's quite a game a
beautiful game to enjoy uh let's dive
straight into it so Anish with the white
pieces opens with D4 we have Knight to
F6 by Magnus C for E6 now Knight to F3
going for the antonym so uh and the
Magnus goes for B6 the Queen's Indian
defense still the most popular reply to
White's um Knight to F3 uh we often say
that even though yeah Alpha zero said
that it's really bad for black it's uh
the problem is humans are just not able
to play on the level of alpha zero and
the Magnus says all right let's let's
see what you got against the Queen's
Indian defense with G3 by a niche
defianchetto variation and the bishop to
A6 now we we had this few days ago uh
where uh of course the C4 Pawn is
hanging and B3 was played uh but now
Anish plays Queen to C2 which is a
little bit different because not only
does it defend the C4 pawn it also
controls the E4 Square so E4 is now
something black should worry about so
Magnus just plays Bush back to B7 sort
of a Tempo loss but um this is how the
line is played Bishop to G2 we have Pawn
to C5 and now Pawn to D5 we have E
Capture C captures and now Knight
captures on D5 so Magnus wins a pawn
here uh but it's upon that's uh not uh
easily kept so here Anish castles with
Bishop to E7 and now Rook the D1 just
puts pressure on the Knight and the
Magnus plays Knight to C6 he blunders
the Knight on D5 I'm only kidding of
course if Anish were to capture the
Knight the Knight before attacks the
Queen the rook and also the Rook is
attacked twice so you would lose the
exchange here so instead after Knight
the C6 Anish plays Queen to F5 it's a
very nice active Square for the for the
queen and it puts pressure on the Knight
on D5 so here at night back to F6 by
Magnus we have Pawn to E4 preparing to
grab more space with E5 and the Magnus
plays D6 here here G6 is the more
popular move just kicking the queen away
but Magnus goes for D6 and now he
invites Pawn to E5 we have Pawn to E5 by
Anish and interestingly Magnus Carlsen
already plated this exact same position
with the white pieces in I believe some
2009 against the Yannick Pelletier uh
we're Magnus won so uh he he knows what
he's doing here
uh and there's only one good move here
if you if you play something weird you
just get destroyed Queen to D7 is the
only move and you give up the D6 Pawn so
here Queen captures on D7 Knight
captures on D7 e captures on D6 and now
Magnus gets this beautiful diagonal for
his dark Square Bishop so here Rook to
E1 by a niche with King to f8 and now
Knights the C3 and here Magnus goes
Knight to B4 uh opens up this diagonal
that's always an issue for black in the
Queen's Indian defense and also
threatens Knight the C2 which would win
material and there are many ways you can
meet Knight to B4 you can play Rook 8 to
be a rook to B1 you can play Rook to D1
you can just play maybe even Rook to E2
you can play Bishop to G5 many many cool
ideas here but Anish goes for Knight the
E5 and the bishop to G5 is the move that
Magnus played against the ionic uh in
the game that he won but here Knight the
E5 by Niche is a new move so now already
as of move 18 uh we have a completely
new game that's how my Theory went into
this and as Anish played it obviously he
has it prepared now the question is
where Magnus has it also prepared and
this is about the time that Magnus
started uh started actually thinking so
here Knight captures on E5 grabbing that
you don't have to play this you could
play something like Rook to Da just
defend the Knight but Knight captures on
E5 is best with Bishop captures and B7
now comes Rook to d8 and of course Rook
to D1 not allowing the knights to Fork
your Rooks so Magnus goes Knight to C4
now puts pressure on the D6 spawn and
Anish advances it all the way to D7 so
it looks a bit weird to allow uh the
Pono to be on D7 but um this is uh well
if you know your stuff you can win the
pawn back but only if you know your
stuff Magnus goes Knight to C2 it comes
with Tempo with the rook and A1 so
Anisha has to waste the move and the
Magnus will bring the Knight back to D4
we have rooked the B1
uh and now the question is how do you
continue this game uh Magnus played
Knights the D4 and this uh is the start
of uh of big problems for magnets the
way you play this is you have to play
Knight to E5 you just go after the pawn
win the pawn and that's pretty much it
uh then uh you you no longer have to
worry about the past D7 pawn and even if
something like Bishop to see a C8
displayed it's not a problem then you
play Knights to D4 and of course you
still win the D7 Pawn however Magnus
played Knight to D4 right away and here
uh this is what I always talk about when
I show you games and you guys always
think that I'm joking around uh but
always always in every position check if
you have Pawn to B4 if Pawn to B4 is a
possibility you should check it whether
you're white or black it's a move that
simply decides most of the games on
every level even at the absolute highest
level like Anish versus Magnus and here
Anish of course played this Pawn to B4
and it looks like it does absolutely
nothing but what it does is everything
thing now the problem is okay you can't
capture obviously but what happens if
you uh if you if you for example uh just
ignore it you go Knights the E5 let's
say you go after the D7 Pawn well that's
the best uh thing you can do for example
B captures on C5 B characters and C5 and
not Knight the E4 now the C5 Pawn is
also Weak by playing B captures on C5
you weakened another one of Black's
pawns and now you Bishop to E7 defending
it okay black defended now and now you
play You're Gonna capture on D7 now
white advances the Ponte A4 and it's
still uh difficult for black to play
this you have to bring the Rook into the
game you have to get your king somewhere
while White's entire Army is already
mobilized and ready for action uh but
still Knight the E5 is the best way to
play this Magnus missed the real threat
behind Pawn to B4 and he played Rook
captures on D7 right away and now the
game is just completely winning for
Anish giri but you have to figure out
what Anish saw with this E4 plan feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for a niche while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
absolute brilliancy and for those of you
who just won't enjoy the show it is
Bishop to D5 absolutely Spectacular Now
uh what you are doing is you are
attacking the Knight on C4 and there's
uh no no good Square for the Knight and
also you are getting your your Bishop to
safety that's also one of the uh one of
the nicer ideas of this bishop to D5
move uh so how do you play this uh well
Knight's the D6 knight uh other moves
don't really help the Magnus Knight the
D6 was played now look at this B
captures and C5 B captures and C5 and
now you could go Rook to B8 with check
but you also don't have to and he just
plays Bishop to A3 and now look at
anisha's Bishop Fair absolutely uh
spectacular The Rook also can come to B8
with check so Magnus has to decide how
to how to play this if you go something
like Rook to C7 to defend the C5 Pawn
then you allow Rook to B8 with check and
now you have to block this somehow it's
blocked with the Rook then again the C I
have five Pawn will hang after we trade
Rooks so we're going to have have to
play Knight the C8 and now that should
be seven just wins that night so uh you
can't go for that so after Bishop day
three Magnus finds King to E7 it's a
very good move uh but now he just uh
gives up the C5 pawn bishop captures on
C5 and it's not like Anish won any
material Anisha actually was done
material now he just regained material
uh the problem is that anisha's Bishop's
pair is simply Unstoppable here uh
Magnus plays Knight to E6 he puts
pressure on the bishop Here and Now
anigo goes Bishop to B4 and this move
allows Magnus to get back into the game
here I will just show you a line that
completely destroys Magnus and that is
Knight to E4 now uh how do you how do
you play this there's so much pressure
on this Knight on D6 uh you will play
Knight captures on C5 but now Knight
captures on C5 attacks the rook and once
The Rook moves Rook the E1 with check
King to d8 and now Knight the A6 attacks
is The Rook you have to go back Rook to
C8 and now Bishop captures on F7 ended
the black king will not be able to
survive the the two white Rooks the
bishop the Knight here uh this is uh
just Unstoppable uh but okay Bishop to
B4 was played it's not easy to calculate
everything and of course you don't want
to spend all of your time because then
you're just not gonna have enough time
regardless of how winning your position
is and here Magnus has a way back into
the game but he misses it here he plays
Pawn to A5 he wants to unpin
um uh from this nasty pin and again a
Tempo to bring his Rook into the game
but the way you uh the way you play this
is eliminate one of the attackers Bishop
captures on C3 and after Bishop captures
now you play Knight to F5 and now after
a move like if you try Bishop Bishop to
B for check you can go King F6 if you go
Bishop to C3 check you just go King E7
so that's not working for white so white
will have to try something okay white
still has the spectacular Bishop's pair
but still after work characters real
characters you will bring your Rook into
the game and now well whether you can or
cannot defend this with black that's up
to how how good you can hold a passive
position the bishop Perry is still
absolutely spectacular whether he would
be able to hold this it is hard to say
but after the move in the game Pawn to
A5 now he just gives up a pawn for no
counter play uh a niche captures that we
have rooked to C8 and now Anish just
plays Knights to A4 and that's the the
tricky move that Anish had to find now
it seems like Rook day 7 will just
attack the bishop in the night so what's
up with that it's a very very tricky
line uh that Anish had to deeply
calculate in order to even play this the
point is look at this bishop to B4 and
now if you don't capture then the Knight
can just come to B6 and if you capture
then you have Bishop captures and D6
with check and black has the moves if
you capture then you just play Bishop to
B7 check open up a discovery attack The
Rook here after King the C7 juror just
rooted to C1 and and you will suffer too
much material or skin will move real
captors and see it with the check and
now even after King Day 7 you even have
the flashy Rook to E8 to check captors
and now you just trade Rooks for example
Bishop captures an A4 and you're down
the exchange but uh blacks Down The
Exchange but also the past a pawn will
be unstoppable so the problem is after
Bishop captures on D6 you will have to
just move the king but it's not much
better Rook to B7 and black is without a
move here there's really nothing you can
play you can never move the The Rook
from the C file Bishop to c6s is game
over uh you can't move the Knight
because Bishop captures an F7 I mean
there's no move you can play here so
instead uh after this Knight A4 move
Magnus does not go for Rook to A7 he
goes for Knight to C4 which is even
worse than Rook t7 according to the
engine but maybe it gives Anish a few
more chances to make an error and now
Bishop to B4 check is winning but Anish
first goes for Rook B to C1 it doesn't
to give Magnus all that many chances
Magnus plays Bishop to E5 magnus's only
chance is anisha's time but still Anish
has 16 minutes Magnus says 10 minutes uh
and the 9 more moves until time control
uh 16 minutes seems like way too much
time for Anish to finish a position like
this and here we have Bishop to B4 with
check uh here if you try to rush it a
little bit and this was probably Magnus
says maybe Last Hope of survival if you
try to capture on C4 if you go for Rook
captures on C4 then Rook captures on D5
and now it doesn't matter what you play
through capture sincere Rook capture Sun
D1 and now maybe Rook day one and you
might have a chance to hold this uh and
also after Bishop to E5 if you go for
something like Bishop captures on C4
then Rook characters and D1 Rook
captures and real captures on C4 again
black has some chances of saving this
but Anish says Nope now we're just gonna
do what was already in the position a
move ago Bishop D5 really doesn't change
the position all that much Bishop to B4
check King the F7 by Magnus but still
Knight The Thief sorry Knights the C5
again with the same idea The Rook is
hanging and the Knight on C4 is hanging
so Knight captures on C5 has to be
played Rook captures on C4 and now Rook
D to C7 and now Anish just plays Bishop
to A5 and he was in this position and
move 35 that Magnus Carlsen resigned the
game and what a spectacular victory for
Anish giri who also takes the lead in
the Tata steel tournament I don't know
how the other games will end up but at
least a lead maybe a short lead but for
now after round four uh he is in the
lead of the title still tournament not
only that he dealt a a
severe loss to Magnus Carlson as you
guys know uh he does not lose classical
games very often but uh well there you
have it Anish played a spectacular game
Magnus tried everything here he wanted
to play an interesting opening he played
the Queen's Indian defense which now you
see why it's not so easy to play uh it
doesn't matter if you're up a pawn for
the entire game white always has that
activity uh compensation that Alpha zero
could nurture to to like Perfection uh
but even humans are able to do it as you
can see if you if you give a slight
chance in the position uh but yeah where
did it all go wrong for Magnus well I'm
sure I don't even have to tell you but
um after Rook to B1 of course you know
uh Knight to D4 and if Magnus just
checked Pawn to B4 then he would see
that everything opens up that the B file
opens up that the diagonal opens up he
didn't check it and no one is stronger
uh you know no one is above checking
Pawn to B4 if you don't check it you're
just gonna lose games so always be
careful about that checkpoint to be for
whatever your white whatever black it
most likely is the the mood that will
decide the game uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it very
nicely done by Anish who now has
excellent chances of winning the
tournament but it's still very early to
to say anything we'll see how the rest
of the tournament goes for him uh so I
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Dominic pinteridge Suraj Kota
Dominic iseli Jeffrey Munster and the
Richard F syage for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing uh the coverage of the Tata
steel Challengers and the Masters until
it finishes so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day